all right ellen
ellen where'd you grow up where are you
from originally florida wonderful
orlando and tell me about your family
you had mom and dad growing up
yes i did
[Music]
i had a mother i had a mother
father nothing much yeah
how would you describe your childhood in
general
decent
pretty decent
no abuse nothing no no definitely not
but your dad was not so much in the
picture
no
it was when i got older i got older it
was yeah
what kind of game were you in high
school
huh what kind of kid were you in high
school
um
you finished high school
no
yeah how far did you go
and what'd you do after that
if i was where i had a construction job
at first i'm sorry i had a construction
job at first construction job yeah
how old do you know
38 38.
you've been living on the streets in new
york for how long
since august of 2018.
it's about four years yeah
and you're panhandling yeah that's how
you make a buck yeah that's how much you
make a day
if you were like 35 that's what you
doesn't go far in new york city no
definitely not where do you stay at
night on the train you sleep on the
train yeah
so we don't have training tonight
tell me about living on the streets in
in new york
yeah sucks
school
it's not cold now it was cool
it's
not that fun how'd you end up in this
situation
a friend told me to come up here and
he had let me stay with him you know it
didn't work out
are drugs a part of your life
are drugs a part of your life
okay
yeah
crystal meth no no
what do you use
who heroin no is it fentanyl here in new
york yeah yeah
it's fentanyl everywhere now
you started using drugs
at what age
18 19.
have you had time where you've been
clean
yeah
how's your clean
detox yeah
do you have kids
no i do not okay you've been loved
before
yes no yeah
married
no
no married
i wasn't engaged for a while never
you speak to your family at all anymore
so you're are you on your own now yeah
you have nobody
no i'm a sister
really really cooks
what kind of stuff have you been through
since you've been homeless
different
um
[Music]
just
sleeping outside in the rain or the snow
it's not fun there's nothing
you get hurt when you're out here
anything like that
whatever
yeah
yeah people try to rob me and [ __ ]
before
you're gonna rob a homeless man yeah
[ __ ]
how does this life that you're living
affect you emotionally you get depressed
or angry or anything like that
you're bruised you're depressed yeah
yeah
you stay depressed
do you have friends at all
yeah they help you you do
people on the street or actual friends
people on the street yeah yeah
what are the ways are they to make money
other than panhandling
[Music]
and getting a job is not an option
it is but i don't have an idea
with my
[Music]
what do you worry about
what do i worry about yeah what are you
afraid of
being still
forever
do you think there's a chance you'll be
down here the rest of your life
[Music]
think about going back to florida yeah
so it's way cheaper to live down there
foreign
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
finish school
not one enough to not use heroin after
wanting to be
[Music]
in school not use everyone's
there's a
were you working a job while you were
doing heroin
yeah
so you were somewhat functional for a
while
i was looking discussion jokes
everyone enjoyed working with a musical
what was your favorite memory
in your life
[Music]
do you remember
you can't think of one
huh you can't pick a one
yeah civil
um
me and my ex-girlfriend the first time
that was one
are there good aspects to this lifestyle
that you're living
you don't have to go to work
no
no
you'd rather
have your old life back or yeah oh yes
one
you know it's like sleeping on the
streets or only training yourself so
you and if i don't make money or
whatever after that i might be attracted
to this yeah there's nothing
[Music]
how much do you spend a day on
on fentanyl
yeah how much do you spend a day
muscle
pan head before
whatever i do whatever i don't need
whatever
what do you do for food
do you go through garbage
sometimes
let's go out to a cheap restaurant
mcdonald's or taco bell
get someone that's a few dollars
alan what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
most importantly listen
most important lesson would be
not to quit on stuff you're doing
i could
put a lot of stuff
all right that probably would change the
losses
i'm sorry it probably would change
50 percent of this situation
your life would be different if you
hadn't given up so easily
yeah
all right alan thank you so much for
sharing your story
i like your night a little bit nicer
thank you a little bit easier thanks
you